hope you have a merry day off parents
are calling for resignations after a
school board in new jersey voted to
remove
all holiday names from its academic
calendar
the reason to avoid hurting people's
feelings
so now federal holidays will be referred
to as days off
parents are fed up and saying the school
board members need to
step down i think it's
it's social media combined with
political ideologies
and people that are in positions of uh
you know
perceived power are pushing their
personal agendas instead of really doing
what they're entrusted to
this uh radical theme that we've seen
for the last 12 months
occur across the country is coming to
your neighborhood soon
help greg i don't think they've gone far
enough what are we gonna do about the
days of the week remember
they're named after planets but the
planets are named after gods and all of
them are men but one
who is venus who gave birth to cupid who
was responsible for creating a binary
restrictive sexual fascism
you got mars who's the god of war that's
actually tuesday so he's got to go
you could probably just go from monday
which is the moon to wednesday
but wednesday is mercury and mercury is
the god of finance
so that's we got to change all those
names this hyper
kind of hypersensitivity is being
marshaled to tear down this country and
i know that sounds far-fetched
but if you get really deep into it it's
about recreating america as oppressor
versus oppressed
and it's like every revolution that is
successful
it's being it's being controlled and
created by a very tiny minority
it's a very small number of people who
buy into this stuff but that's all you
need to scare the crap out of human
resources
executives politicians and bureaucrats
who are so
frightened they will throw everybody
under the bus thinking that
they might not get hit what's weird
about this town and this county dana i
looked at the voter registrations
this is a republican county it is a
republican town that
about three-quarters of the registered
voters in this town
are either republican or like
independent unaffiliated it's a quarter
democrat
so what it goes to is these people join
the town council or join the school
board
because they want to lay on their
not-so-wacko ideology
on the whole town and so now the parents
are like wait a minute
what the hell is going on here but it
could happen anywhere it only takes two
people
it can and the thing is is that a lot of
those people that are good citizens they
probably vote in every election
but they probably don't really pay too
much attention as to who's going to be
on the school board this is happening
all across america all of a sudden like
wait
this person ran for school board why
shouldn't i run for school board i think
that people like the parents that we
just saw
are part of a new grassroots movement
that is like the tea party they just
don't quite know it yet
and the reason why is you think about
obamacare you might not have been able
to say to like
a person walking down the street what is
it what is it about obamacare then all
the complexities that make you upset
about it
they just knew that it just didn't feel
right and that is what you're starting
to see with critical race theory and
other types of things like this with the
school boards people can't they can't
exactly tell you exactly what's going on
but they know that it's not the
direction that they want to go so i do
think you'll see a lot more parents
at the school board meetings or possibly
even running for office because
the democrats are now even being warned
by their strategist so third-party
people going oh guys maybe there's
a little bit too much here richard so
the the fight in this town started over
columbus day
and instead they turned around and
canceled everything including dr martin
luther king jr oh my god
well that was that's upset listen
i where i agree where it's i agree with
this kid where it started now where it's
ended is something completely different
uh i do
understand people who have problems with
columbus day because i think there's a
very clear reason to number one
columbus in the first european to touch
on american shores it was actually the
vikings
right the vikings saw the indians and
they had they sort of trade with them
but they didn't settle here
but we celebrate columbus as sort of the
first european we can argue that another
day
we can my point is is that the
indigenous that's a fair argument and a
fair debate
debating tobacco to us fair
right but but i i think you know i i the
idea of getting rid of all the days on
the calendar
is not a good idea um but to your point
dana i do think that that you know
there's
certain things that over time people
begin to like them obamacare is one of
those things as people begin to
as obamacare begin to begin to be
implemented if you talk to folks in
kentucky they love kentucky connect
which is
obamacare in kentucky right or or the
program in califor cal what is the cal
healthcare in california or the exchange
in dc so it's we have to get away from
the labels and the talking points and
actually talk about the policy
actually is in this particular case this
school board passed bad policy
and that's why we're talking about it on
the show today but this is the desired
outcome
for much of the left to my point is to
create
a a communist-like sameness
among everything they want to get rid
this school board
wants to get rid of thanksgiving but
that's the school board that's not the
whole entire democratic party
it's pounds right i agree with richard i
think we should all get days off for
viking day
that was a good point i just can't
imagine the women in new jersey getting
the calendar in the mail and and seeing
the calendar and then tacking it up on
the fridge and seeing the third thursday
in november be thanksgiving
just dropping their diet coke on the
floor no
new jersey parents don't get offended
they offend other people
this is we're talking about new jersey
here right i was in new jersey home
goods the other day shopping and i had
my car piled high as heck right
and i'm shopping i'm shopping all of a
sudden can't find my cart
and i'm looking around and i'm looking
around all of a sudden all the items
in my cart have been emptied out on the
couch and someone has stolen my shopping
cart
these people don't get offended by
thanksgiving these people are giving
people black eyes on black friday
these are the kind of people that don't
get offended and you're right you take
away martin luther king day
black americans are upset christmas
christians are upset they've offended
more people
by trying to be politically correct we
should change the name of the town
did you know the town was founded by a
wealthy landowner
heartstorm fitzrandolph he ran the
indians off their land there you go and
then big iron mine used to make weapons
for the continental army very violent
very aggressive i see we call it blank
new jersey now
i know johnny is good
i was mad that you got your car stolen
at home goods my cart was stolen
it could be you're just reaping what you
sowed but you know hey maybe somebody's
targeting maybe you stole your card from
somebody
exactly yeah what do you think this is
karma yes yes
[Laughter]
they didn't like what was in your cart
and it needed to be replaced with more
sensitive items well listen
whatever it is victim
victim victim shaming hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else